[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
chessopenings.com
of course last week we went over the
advanced variation this week I wanted to
cover the exchange of course these two
main lines are well-named
if I can show you on the board here the
advanced of course that we covered last
week is when white advances the pawn
forward in the exchange as you might
expect is when you exchange the pawns on
d5 and so this is a main variation in
the caro-kann that I wanted to spend a
little bit of time talking about with
you tonight because there are some very
testing variations in here normally when
tension in the center is decided like
this so early on it can lead to some
slightly more boring positions where
each side isn't really getting into it a
huge battle in the center right away but
with this exchange white has this choice
really of a few different lines and all
of them give black a problem to solve so
we're gonna look to see what problems
white can pose to black and how black
can go about solving them so today the
first variation I wanted to cover with
you guys is this variation that starts
with Bishop d3 now Bobby Fischer friends
out there might know that this was one
of his favorite lines with Bishop d3 and
already with Bishop d3 white is kind of
declaring how he wants to play the
position and which problem he's giving
black to solve so of all of the black
pieces these two knights are going to
have very natural squares this Bishop
can easily come out to d6 what's the
only piece that might have problems
getting developed well it's this bishop
on CA and so with Bishop d3 white takes
control of this natural f5 Square that
this Bishop might want to develop itself
to and says this is going to be your
problem in the opening how do you
develop this Bishop and I'm going to
suggest a line that gets this Bishop
developed anyways kind of just crams it
and whites face regardless of what he
wants to do so first and foremost it's
most natural to develop the Knights
first so knight c6 is a pretty natural
move hitting this pawn white will likely
play C 3 now for those of you viewing
can any of you tell me why Knight f3
isn't the most common move here why
might White be avoiding Knight f3 2 to
defend this pawn there's a question for
you guys at home in the YouTube chat
here Knight f3 looks like a natural
developing move it certainly defends
this pawn on d4 but but what's the
problem here
what's the problem here
okay there's a bit of a delay at home I
don't want to spend too much time
I'm sure the YouTube chat are is full of
geniuses who already know of course this
isn't in line with White's opening place
so far so far white played Bishop d3 and
the purpose was we wanted to make it
difficult for black to develop the
bishop and yet everybody has it now
with Knight f3 you're simply giving
black this g4 square now so it doesn't
make quite so much sense to allow black
to develop like this which is why we see
the slightly less natural c3 just
defending this d4 pawn keeping an eye on
this g4 square as well now there are two
main lines here for black the older
mainline is Queen c7 and Queen c7 kind
of adopts the same approach that white
adopted with Bishop d3 Queen c7 is
simply guarding this f4 square
preventing this Bishop from coming here
and this is a perfectly acceptable way
of playing but I'm actually going to
recommend the other line which goes with
Knight f6 now of course Knight f6 can
allow Bishop f4 and we'll certainly talk
about what happens if white chooses to
play there but it does one more a very
very important thing and that is it
controls the g4 square so now if white
wants to stick to his guns stick to
preventing this bishop from getting
developed he's going to have to play h3
on this turn and this is the main
variation that I wanted to cover here
today of course Bishop f4 is a perfectly
playable move and it does take advantage
of the fact that white did not play
Queen or black did not play Queen c7 of
course though now after Knight f6 and
Bishop f4 black has this opportunity to
play Bishop g4 and from what I've found
black really doesn't have any problems
in this variation just to show you a
line Queen b3 is by far the most popular
response that hits b7 so a common way to
play is simply Queen c8 defending this
pawn and supporting this Bishop a little
bit now white gets developed with Knight
d2 black gets developed with ease 6 you
might see 9 GF 3 a simple Bishop e7 note
this is another downside to allowing
this
to f4 our Bishop has to kind of settle
for the e7 square rather than the d6
square castles castles rook e1 is very
common for white and now Bishop h5 kind
of reveals the the purpose of this
Bishop here black gets it out to g4 but
on g4 it doesn't really look that
impressive it attacks this knight which
isn't even pins this Knight wants to
move to e5 anyways but black is gonna
drop this Bishop back to g6 and trade it
off for White's LightSquared bishop and
with this exchange black is really not
going to be any worse at all just to
show you one example game here we'll see
how this game continued with 95 and I
take c5 bishop takes and after Bishop g6
they simply exchanged white played h3
black got this Queen to a better square
and they exchanged some pieces and
agreed to a draw eventually so if an
h-file is both a strength and a weakness
with black putting some pressure here
but e 6 is there really only only the
open is really the only weak spot in
blacks camp and his piece is olive good
squares and so this game was agreed to a
draw I will just flip through it very
very quickly
black open the H file like this kept an
eye on this e6 pawn and after some
controversy the the game was agreed to a
draw in this position so no real
problems for black is the point of what
I was saying here with that in mind I do
think the more testing variation is not
bish about for allowing black to get
this Bishop developed I think the
slightly more testing variation is
actually with h3 and it seems to violate
some opening principles to move so many
pawns like this so early on but white is
really sticking to his guns here and
saying you're gonna have a tough time
developing the bishop now does anybody
at home already know this idea I wonder
if if you've got it in mind why does it
show Oh what if they agree to a draw
that was a sideline I was showing what
happens at Bishop f4 we're looking now
at the main move age
in this game if you at home have any
ideas on how we can get this mission
developed please share it now the answer
is about to be revealed to you it might
be a sensible time to simply give up and
just develop the dark square bishop the
move e5 is really common here but this
isn't actually what I'm gonna recommend
it's perfectly fine way of playing but I
like the slightly more combative g6
instead now after Knight f3 will develop
this Bishop to g7 white will get castled
and then you guessed it we're actually
still going to develop our Bishop out to
f5 so this is my proposed solution to
the problem that white posed us with
this opening blacks problem in this
opening was how do I develop the bishop
and this is the solution I'm
recommending you play g6 you fianchetto
and you bring this bishop out to f5 now
for example if white ignores this Bishop
out here on f5 we can simply go for a
trade on d3 and it's much like the
previous line I looked at where black
trades off his bad Bishop quote-unquote
for White's best minor piece this bishop
on d3 and you really shouldn't have too
many problems just for an example line
this is from a game of alekseyev against
ur off yeah it was a rapid game I
believe but it's a little beside the
point just to show you some moves the
game can often continue like this and
after a move like u 6 you see black
structure is very very solid common
ideas are you're just going to bring
this knight in to c4 after move like
rook c8 for example and really there's
there's nothing to play it for with
white with black however if you still
want to try to play for win you can
consider things like going for a
minority type of attack after you
improve this Knight things like that
there's definitely still stuff to play
for here other than that of course the
testing variation is to actually snap
this Bishop off the board with Bishop
takes f5 this of course fractures the
black pawn structure and you end up with
this kind of funny-looking structure
in the center for black now the upside
to this is you really gain a stronghold
square on the e4 point if you stir if
you drop a knight into the e4 square
they're really the only way white will
be able to kick it out is with the move
f3 + f3 isn't so much a move that white
really wants to play it very much
weakens the remainder of these dark
squares around the King and it kicks the
knight back to d6 where it's not really
a bad square at all it can even I the
c-4 square or back to the e4 square if
need be so you gain this efore point
this is the big upside of course the
downside is the King's side feels a
little bit loose a little bit weak this
H pawn is isolated and these pawns are
of course doubled so white is going to
look to make use of that that weakness
now but we didn't give it away for
nothing for one we got our Bishop
developed in for two we gain this really
strong point on e6 so Bishop f4 is the
most natural way for white to develop
I'm gonna recommend castles for black
and now 95 white points out that we have
the e4 square but you still has the e5
square now simply e6 makes a lot of
sense to defend the rest of our pawns
now 92 and 97 this is a fairly common
maneuver here for black bringing the
knight over to the King side to guard
some squares and force this Bishop to a
slightly less comfortable spot than a f4
the game continued with rook e1 now
Knight g6 does come on the board and
this Bishop drops back to h2 of course
we are eventually going to make use of
this efore a square and white chose to
do so or black chose to do so now with
Knight to e4 and now Knight e3 comes on
the board and we simply continue
improving our pieces as we do in most
variations of chess I would say the
opening is more or less complete now and
we're solidly in the middle game
as for where we kind of stand in this
middlegame position it's all about this
efore square this knight on e4 is a
really really powerful piece and it's
going to be tough to dislodge without
playing f3 so white is eventually
probably going to commit to this smooth
in the meantime
black can do a lot of useful things for
example this Bishop isn't its brightest
on the g7 square so in the game black
had developed it out to age six and now
it's it's looking a lot of a lot of
uncomfortable squares and the reason I
like this so much for black is the
pieces all seem to have a purpose they
seem to work together and it is actually
black who is stronger in the center now
the game can go a lot of ways from here
but just to show you how this game
developed white went for Knight f3
aiming for this e5 square and black now
with the benefit of having these double
pawns can guard both the f6 both the e5
square in the e4 square with f6 and f5
so f6 comes on the board to stop any 95
business now white tries to get at this
weakness a little bit b6 is a pretty
nice move by black just stops the white
knight from ever coming into c5 Queen b3
was White's choice rook c8 makes sense
to guard c4 King h1 came on the board
Queen d7 guards some weaknesses our a e1
to get at east six King h8 Knight g1 the
unfortunate truth for white is that the
black pieces are well-placed enough for
that night g1 is the only way to get
this Knight out of the way to play f3
now we saw Ricky eight who simply guard
this pawn f3 black actually chose the D
2 square hitting this Queen Queen D one
night c4 and now in the game white found
nothing better than to actually play f4
perhaps he could have tried something
like g4 but I really don't believe it's
so much for white if he does play like
this well he might get hit with the move
f4 by black himself when black is
looking to plant this night onto E
three so that's why f4 was chosen
largely to prevent f4 from black but now
of course this once again gives up the
e4 square and after night of 394 I can't
imagine a world where black ever loses
loses this game with this strong central
night compared to these these shattered
white pieces black did end up going on
to win actually and I will show it
quickly g4 was played F takes aged takes
and now eventually black expands on the
queenside a little bit comes up with
this move f5
it's a nice move to keep this Bishop a
little bit hemmed in G takes that five e
takes f5 and we see the stronghold on e4
persisted up until white broke and
captured giving black this nice passed
pawn Knight g5 was White's choice Rick
f6 and Bishop back to age six you know
this Knight kind of invades Queen d5 is
a very nice move pressuring this White
King rookie three but now Knight f3 and
rich e6 or takes h takes a three King g7
Bishop g3 b5 from Black Knight g1 and
then I'll let you at home try and find
Blacks next move it's a it's a pretty
fun one
takes advantage of some pins and it's a
great way to reroute the night I did
kind of blow through this middle game
but I wanted to largely focus on the
opening and we saw that it was a lot of
maneuvering in the middle cam but it's
all about this g4 square in the end that
was kind of the point while you think
about blacks next move here
see if you can find it see if you can
find it
okay Bishop takes f4 has been suggested
which is ambitious but it does lose a
piece you get a check but I'm not sure
it's quite enough here you're not quite
checkmating me just yet not quite
checkmating yeah Aakash has it it's of
course 95 when this pawn is pinned and
this pawn is pinned and thus knights
coming in to to g4 a pretty nasty move
here
Queen f1 was White's choice now Rick
headshake makes a threat so King g2 and
now Knight g4 and this King really
doesn't have any squares Rickey one was
played and black actually brought the
rook back over to c8 and King g8 black
really took his time in this game but he
was winning kind of threw out from from
this point onwards eventually III came
on the board and black got at this King
and here white ended up actually
resigning
so of course why didn't play perfectly
this game the point was when you get
this efore stronghold the point was this
is kind of what the the game revolves
around black having this efore strong
point and white trying to kick this
Knight out of the way but then blacks
pieces are already so active that white
doesn't have a ton that he can really do
about it
that's why I like this line so much
black really takes the initiative plants
the knight on e4 and forces white to
come up with ideas so that's all I have
on this line of the exchange with Bishop
d3 of course this is kind of the
favorite of Bobby Fischer
just to recap the point of Bishop d3 is
to take away these squares from the
bishop and so of all the lines I covered
the point is we're trying to solve this
Bishop on c8 with Knight f6 we're
threatening to bring it up to g4 after
h3 prevents that we play g6 to bring it
out to f5 and in this main variation we
get this fun structure in the center
where we have this nice efore control
and all the other variations we wind up
trading this Bishop off before this
Bishop on D
and with these pieces off the board it
comes a lot more difficult to pressure
black but the white pieces okay I think
we're just about ready to move on and go
with this game between the one and only
of a silly Ivanchuk and ebony Niger of
course we are looking at the exchange
caro-kann this is the starting position
and last game we took a look at some
various lines involving Bishop d3 this
game I wanted to test you guys out on
perhaps the most testing variation or at
least introduced it with c4 and this is
what our final two games of the day are
going to be in here this pan of attack
with c4 so in the previous variation the
problem for black was this Bishop on c8
trying to get it developed in this
variation white takes a slightly more
aggressive approach try and then simply
hamper trying rather than simply
hampering blacks development white is
going to go after this central pawn on
d5 just attacking it directly and asking
black how are you going to defend this
point and in this game I'm going to
recommend a line which might not be
popular with the viewers it is of course
the infamous endgame line in the
caro-kann so these first developing
moves are pretty much the only ways
white and black both play and then after
Knight f3 this is white kind of saying
he's he's prepared to go into this
endgame line the other choice is Bishop
g5 which we're gonna take a look at in
the next game but for this game Knight
f3 and here unfortunately
I I think the best line for black is
honestly to go into this endgame line
you can do other things here for example
if you want to avoid the endgame line
entirely
this is g6 line isn't bad for black at
all the game might continue with
something like Queen b3 Bishop g7 you
give up this pawn for a moment and get
castled and these lines are a lot of
but I think the endgame line is simply
solid for black and like should be doing
absolutely fine so that's line I'm gonna
recommend if you're interested at home
though you can take a look at these g6
lines they're not so bad but okay I'm
recommending knight c6 when after Knight
f3 Bishop g4 is accepting the endgame
line variation the line continues in a
pretty forcing manner white takes on d5
black of course recaptures now white
plays this move Queen b3 this Knight is
hanging black takes this moment though
to play the nice move Bishop takes f3
taking off this Knight and guarding this
Knight back here on d5
white has to recapture now this Knight
is still hanging so the move is c6 to
defend it but of course white can take
on b7 now this hangs the d4 pawn so
black will take now Bishop b5 check is
the point of whites play we have to take
this back then of course white is not
going to play at Queen takes b5 rather
including this move Queen c6 check and
this is kind of the point
miss placing blacks King
ever-so-slightly by giving this check
forcing it up to e7 now white can
capture this night we will play Queen d7
in response offering a trade the Knight
takes d5 Queen takes d5 Queen takes d5
he takes d5 and we have arrived at the
main starting position of our endgame
line didn't he lose to kill he did lose
to Caleb in response to the bring
Jonathan trance back comment just to
briefly go over what just happened again
so white was putting a lot of pressure
here we just developed naturally and
then white cashes in on d5 we take a
moment to fracture White's pawn
structure but give up our b7 pawn in
exchange for the d4 pawn and white
develops with check and white gets to
prevent black from castling and then we
eventually see the trade of the Queen's
and that's how we arrived at this
quote-unquote starting position of the
end
line of course the line is perfectly
named we are in an endgame and there's
actually a few ways that this end game
can go I don't want to go to super
in-depth into an endgame in this
openings class so for this line for
today we're gonna take a look at the
line that was played in the game with
Bishop III I will briefly mention white
also sometimes castles white also
sometimes plays Bishop f4 but in
response to all of these moves black is
going to play King e6 this is the move
for black you develop your King and get
it out of the way at this Bishop which
is likely going to go to the be for
square white can now really castle in
either direction in the game he chose
castles Queen side if for example
castles King side black now really has a
choice of developing the e7 and b4 I'm
gonna recommend developing out to be for
just for consistency's sake you want to
keep an eye on this file to keep your
King a little bit safer in the game
Queen side castles was played and now
Bishop b4 is really the main move once
again just keeping an eye on the e1
Square rook d3 is what white shows in
the game trying to go after this pawn a
little bit black now activates the rooks
immediately with Rick HC a check this
King steps over to b1 and then white
black tries to solve the rest of his
problems with this move Bishop c5 and
this is going to be perfectly fine for
black really nothing not much else to
say really the only way that white can
get an advantage in this line is if he
manages to pressure D the d5 pawn and
rather early on but he really doesn't
get a chance to if black plays as
actively as this for example the
Maverick c1 was played in this game and
simply Bishop takes c3 F take c3 and g5
and not even time to to pressure this
pawn so this is very clearly a draw and
we'll see in the game the players got
there rather quickly
rook a3 they traded off one set of rooks
a5 now
hangover 2 D 1 or B it offers to trade
this pawn for this pawn white of course
wants to decline this so the black herb
doesn't get super active so b3 is played
and now Rick b5 rook a 4 + h5 King e1 +
f5 h3 King d6 King u2 and black takes
this opportunity to simply repeat as
does white as the players have kind of
reached a bit of a standstill here with
the position white could bring this King
up to d4 but it doesn't actually achieve
anything white could kind of try to you
know in escape with this work sorry was
struggling to find the world find the
word escape with this rook back to the D
2 square but once again it really isn't
making any any kind of progress if black
wants to try something you could try
like king e5 but as soon as the King
steps to the square you might get met
with f4 check and now there's simply no
way to create a passed pawn for either
side and as such there's not really any
winning chances so this game was agreed
to a draw and once again just the key
points of this variation this is of
course the endgame line the other one
we're gonna look at is Bishop g5 the key
points are Knight f3 you want to meet
with Bishop g4 just getting your pieces
developed white cashes in on d5 black
cashes in on f3 defending the knight for
a moment and now White's pawns get
fractured but this Queen invades and we
end up in the starting position and
that's really all there is to this line
as for things you have to remember ye 6
is almost almost always the square you
want to put this King on b4 is always
the square you want to put this Bishop
on to support the King on e6 by guarding
a1 and then it's just a matter of
getting your pieces into the game
getting them active and making sure you
keep track of your pawns and that's
about all I have to say about the
endgame line
if white castles right away before
playing Bishop III and black still plays
King e6 isn't it scary with the King the
middle with open fire with the rails
let's take a look so if white castles
King side here and you still play King
e6 isn't it scary well you do get
checked but your King can actually step
up to f5 and it's not at all unhappy
about this here the game might continue
with something like Bishop III when you
could once again just simply play there
should be four or white might actually
just move the rook back over to to d1
here when you can play either rook da or
even came back to e6 both are perfectly
reasonable moves so it's it's really
nothing more than a check and if white
ever tries to get fancy and tries to
check you you can always meet it with f6
just guarding this square and the fact
that these pawns are so fractured is is
really working in black's favor here no
way to get at this King on this nice
solid white square
okay you can draw as black if you know
thirty book moves you don't even have to
know thirty honestly and all of the
moves are pretty natural it's not like
it's a lot of memorization it's a pretty
linear line white takes you you take
back white stops defending this Knight
you take it your Knights attacked you
defend it he takes your pawn you take
his pawn you get checked oh I don't want
to be in check but I take the bishop
I'll got them and check got them with my
King then you offer a clean trade and
you're here
you've made it to the endgame line and
here it's not so much memorization you
just want to put this King on e6 in this
Bishop on d4 and get your hooks into the
game as quickly as possible
without hanging any pawns that's really
all you need to know okay so that's all
I have for this game let's take a look
at our third game of the day between
Levon Aronian and Daniel Stellwagen this
game of course isn't in the exchange
CARICOM and we're looking once again at
this pan off attack with c4 in this case
Knight f6 Knight c3 96 last game we took
a look at the
game line with Knight f3 here I wanted
to introduce you guys to the slightly
more fun line for both sides Bishop g5
this is putting a lot more pressure on
the black position rather than just the
simple Knight f3
of course now there's no Knight that
we're hitting on f3 so it'd be a bit
silly to continue with Bishop g4 now
even a move like Queen b3 wouldn't be
good cuz we would hang this pawn don't
want to forget that but I move like
there should be two it's perfectly fine
for white or even Queen eight for Bishop
g4 is not an awful move by any means but
it just doesn't make as much sense here
with white playing Bishop g5 rather than
Knight f3 now there's a couple ways that
black can play here perhaps even the
most the more respected line is with
Bishop e6 the point is you just kind of
defend this strong point on e6 and due
to the way that White has developed
there's no chance of a Knight g5 kicking
this Bishop out and this is a perfectly
fine way of playing if you want to play
like this I'm not gonna say you can't
play like this line the play might
continue with something like Knight f3
and this Knight can jump into e4 and now
after Knight takes e4 do you take c4 c5
some pieces are going to get traded fork
so Queen d2 Queenie five check Queen III
Queen a5 check this is a well-known drug
and there are just some some peach
traits line like this lines like this
they have to be okay with this is not
what I'm gonna recommend though I'm
gonna recommend the slightly more risky
D takes e4 and the point here is that
we're allowing white to push in the
center if he so desires and we're gonna
take a look at that line briefly but I
wanted to take a look at the most common
line as the main variation in this game
the most common line of course being
Bishop takes c4 so Bishop takes c4 is a
pretty testing line
simply recaptures the pawn and now the
danger for black is if you fall into
this kind of trap I don't know if I can
call it a trap cuz black isn't losing
after he takes but it is kind of
uncomfortable after you take immediately
well the point is black can get into
some danger here if he doesn't know what
he's doing it's gonna be pretty similar
to the lines we're gonna look at in the
game important to play first I think is
this move h6 this gains some time
against this bishop out here on g5 and
it's just a good move to include so
Bishop h4 and now I'm going to recommend
that black takes this pawn on d4 and
this gets you into some pretty forcing
stuff that you have to be a little bit
careful with so Queen takes d4 Knight
takes d4 and Queen side castles is
really the only way to play and here the
danger is if you play kind of a
nonchalant move like knight c6 well
Knight b5 is simply almost checkmate and
certainly winning the game
there's no good response to this move if
you play something like 90 night c6
so now the only real move for black is
to play e5 supporting this knight on d4
now I hear you asking well what if we
try to remove that defender for black
and so there's a couple ways to do that
I'm gonna look first at this most
testing move with f4 and then we're
gonna go back to the game where Levon
Aronian
actually simply just played Knight f3 so
let's start with f4 though f4 hits this
opponent me 5 and I'll turn it over to
the YouTube chat see if you can find a
way to solve this problem of f4 some
method of getting their pieces out such
that you're not losing tonight b5 see if
you can do it
how can we solve this problem of the
knight on d4 and this pressure on e5
what can be done here
play Bishop g4 and hit the rook yeah
that's certainly a good start
so Bishop g4 is the move but of course
now White has a really only only one
main option if you play the move rook d2
trying to be insistent on this idea with
rook d8
you're gonna get met with York c8 when
there's too much pressure on the C file
with this King lined up before these
ideas to really work now if you move
this bishop out of the way for example
the move Knight e4 is going to come with
pretty devastating effect so Bishop g4
is in fact the way to go and why it's
gonna have to respond with Knight f3 now
you can imagine Bishop takes f3 g takes
f3 and then we still have to solve this
problem so Rick c8 is the way to do it
here so Bishop g4 and rook c8 is kind of
the maneuver that you need to know going
into this line otherwise you're gonna
have to find it over the board and
you're probably gonna be terrified while
doing it just a little personal history
I myself fell into this line at some
point before I really knew about it and
was just kind of playing these moves and
hoping for the best and I ended up
losing that game horribly so know your
stuff just play Bishop g4 and rook c8
and then you are pretty much in the
clear there's a couple ways to play now
with white we there's F takes e5 which
hits this knight on f6
and you end up with some piece trades in
this manner but this line isn't really
testing at all the other way to play is
Bishop f1 trying to renew the threat to
e5 and to here
but now what can play the nice move
Knight d5 going after this knight on c3
the game could continue I've take c5 and
it takes c3 B takes c3 and Bishop a3
check this is a really nice developing
move king b1 Knight takes F 3 Bishop h3
it's this rook of course you can't leave
the back rank don't want to fall for
checkmate so Ricky has to be played now
Bishop d7 check this King comes to f8
and eventually black is going to get
developed and have a perfectly fine
endgame
for example in this game it continued
with 37 by the way I'm in a massive side
variation here this is part of the grass
against master of vassal Asst master
vassal Asst with black here just in case
you're wondering and so this game
continued like this and they reached
this endgame which is just totally a
draw now in this game black actually
managed to lose this endgame but that's
beside the point this end games
perfectly fine for black white should
have no pressure at all here once black
gets developed so that was this line
with f4 now we talked about a lot their
key points to remember against f4u-1
Bishop g4 hitting the rook you want to
trade on f3 and you want to play your
xc8 and then the the pressure kind of
alleviates a little bit against F takes
e5 you just trade by taking c4 and
against Bishop f1 you have this nice
move Knight d5 to put pressure on this
night before anything nasty happens to
your king so key points to remember
there now in the main variation after e5
Levon Aronian actually played Knight f3
in this game which is perfectly fine we
are going to play Knight takes f3 in
response doubling white spawns white
actually inserts Bishop takes f6 G takes
f6 and now this should be 5 check and
for the second time today we are met
with a check on this diagonal that we
cannot really block so King e7 once
again is the way to go this happens more
often than you might like in the caret
con but it's the lay of the land it's
what you got to do sometimes and now 95
check looks absolutely terrifying
if you step up to a square like e6000
check could feel a little bit bad but
fortunately for us
King d8 is actually the best move now if
you go in for this check a bit too early
we have 90 for saving our piece so we're
perfectly happy here so white takes the
time to recapture and then the nice
developing move Bishop d6 is what is
kind of holding this position
for black now there's a few ways to play
white shows Rick d2 doubling up the
rooks and now after Bishop c5 Knight b6
once again is a check and is in fact
winning the exchange but in this case
black simply has far too much
compensation here and if anything I
think I would honestly prefer to be the
black pieces here with these two
powerful bishops in this game the game
continued with Bishop d7 black takes on
a 2 getting another pawn now Bishop g4
and Bishop d4 is a really nice move
just totally cuts off these rooks
eliminates their power almost entirely
and black has nothing to fear after f4
the players actually agreed to a draw
but I think black actually does stand a
bit better in this variation here I
think black is doing quite quite well
actually
so certainly an type of position they
could have played on for example a move
like Bishop d5 is reasonable and it's
pretty simple to play with black
actually you can just start pushing
these guys up the board and white is
going to have some serious problems to
have to solve with these strong strong
bishops in the center ok so that was
this variation with Knight f3 you get
checked and you have to look out a
little bit there's this Bishop d6 and
then Knight b6 wins the exchange note
that's a lot of these moves are actually
pretty pretty forced so you do have to
know a little bit what a little bit
about what you're doing here
so Knight f3 you really do want to take
this knight on f3 it's the only way to
solve all these problems now Bishop
takes f6 you do want to take this back
of course this check Keeney sevens the
only move this check King d8 really is
the only move and then Bishop d6 is very
much the only thing to play here but
from there it's fairly natural chess
rook d2 you play Bishop e6 getting
developed you play Bishop c5 and now if
white tries to just like hold the
tension or something with like f4 well
the point of Bishop c5 is this Bishop is
going to sink on the f4
Square this is kind of the point of
blacks play so just remember you have to
remember these few specific moves 9
takes F 3 and then King e 7 and King D 8
and Bishop d6 are important to remember
and then once white kind of goes about
his business you want to plant this
Bishop on the strong d4 square to force
White's hand once this Bishop lands on
d4 black is almost always just doing
perfectly perfectly fine so this is the
idea with Bishop c5 to remember why draw
well Levon Aronian is a very scary
opponent and I've never heard of Daniel
Stellwagen I'm sure he's a great chess
player but with black against Levon
Aronian sometimes you're just happy to
take control can hardly blame the guy
okay so yeah I did skip over the last
critical variation that I want to cover
for the day so we've covered pretty much
all of the exchange and now I want to
talk about the last kind of big hurdle
to overcome in this pan of attack d5 in
this variation does pose some other
problems to blacks so d5 is not
recapturing this pawn on c4 but it is
taking a lot of central space and you
have to be ready to meet this move I'm
gonna recommend the line that goes with
95 and from here sorry one moment don't
know why it flipped okay nyeeehhh five
and from here black can actually sorry
white can actually simply recapture this
pawn on c4 and the like continue with
Knight takes e4 Queen a4 check is
White's point are you getting the piece
Bishop d7 Queen takes c4 and this is I
think one of the more testing lines it's
not actually the main line of this
variation we'll go back and see that as
well but I think this this line does get
black some problems if he's not careful
I'm gonna recommend the move age six and
I wanted to briefly stop and say this h6
move is almost almost always a good
inclusion for black we saw it in the
previous line you wanted to play age six
before you took on d4 it's the case in
this line as well age six is a really
nice move for black to start shaking
loose this Bishop from g5 and give the
black pieces some more freedom in this
game Bishop h4 was played and black
actually continues expanding with g5 and
Bishop g7 is how white or black solve
this problem of the d5 pawn kind of
cramping his position he got developed
in this manner and I think this is
honestly the way to go know that if
white takes on f6 we're happy to take
back with a pawn when a bishop now has a
very very natural square on on d6
you jump into okay stepping back rather
than but should take c4 the main move
here is in fact queen d4 and once again
this is the move h6 this is the way you
want to play now Queen takes d5 doesn't
really give you any problems you simply
take the bishop back and if white wants
to try and take a pawn here he's gonna
get met with b5 and a rude awakening
that the c4 pawn is not going to remain
up for grabs in fact black is holding
this pawn for ever and ever and ever and
moves like rook h5 are also going to be
rather annoying for white to deal with
so probably Bishop takes c4 is a bit
more natural and now simply a6 and if
white wants to take this pawn white can
take this pawn we're not really
concerned about it we like moves like
Queen c7 and already you can start
eyeing the h2 pawn to regain our lost
pawn so Queen takes d5 of course not the
main move Bishop f4 is the main move
against Bishop age 4 you can play a move
like 96 and it's largely the same except
you don't lose a tempo on your knight so
that's why Bishop f4 is much more common
now Knight g6 Bishop g3 would transpose
but the slightly more testing line is
bishop takes c4 and it takes f4 Queen
takes f4 now we do expend with g5
anyways Queen d2 and Bishop g7 and after
night GE 2 and Bishop d7 we are finally
getting our pieces totally developed
black is just going to Castle kingside
and all of his pieces will have squares
despite this strong d5 pawn you can
expect me was like a 6 and b5 to follow
so just lastly if this bishop does end
up on g3 then of course you can't really
play this line with g5 in this case you
simply just bring this pawn out to e6
and against d6 you do have to know your
stuff this move 97 is is the key point
kind of the the problem for black
against this Bishop g3 line or against
any of these lines is getting this darks
we've developed when this pawn is so far
advanced so once again against stuff
like Bishop f4 we simply want to take
this bishop play g5 and develop this way
but if black doesn't allow us if black
plays the move Bishop g3 in response
well then that's when we kind of fall
back on this e six idea we gain some
time on this Bishop so now we can play
e6 these six looks scary but ninety
seven is in fact solving our problems
just to show you a possible continuation
if rook d1 well now Knight f5 is hitting
all three of these pieces this Queen can
come to c5 but now simply Bishop d7 and
black is really not going to have any
problems in this variation as well
there's nothing white can really do to
hold on to this pawn for dear life for
example if simply like Bishop e2 your e2
met with rock c8 and already this Queen
kind of has to leave the defense of this
pawn you can't really stubbornly stay on
it or else you get met with things like
a5 and whoops i trapped a queen so
that's kind of the point of this
variation you just finds some way to get
this Bishop develops and that is really
the three I'm gonna call it three main
lines of the exchange caro-kann that you
absolutely have to know just to do some
quick review here the first line we went
over today is the exchange with Bishop
d3 and against Bishop d3 the problem
black has is how do you develop the
LightSquared Bishop and we solve this
problem by playing knight c6 sorry my
study got a little bit messed up here
tonight f6 threatening to come to g4 and
if white stubbornly stops us we play g6
and get this Bishop out to f5 so these
are the things to keep in mind in this
line you want and all costs to develop
this Bishop now in the second game we
looked at this was of course the endgame
line and while my study really got
messed up okay the endgame line and this
is a very forcing variation
we're black it goes into this endgame
line but he shouldn't have any problems
once again the key things to remember
bring this king to e6 bring this Bishop
to b4 bring this rook into an act of
square and then black is going to be
totally fine
in this endgame and then once again if
you want to avoid this line I'm gonna
recommend a couple things the main line
use to avoid this is to actually play g6
here but against this variation in
particular you can also kind of fall
back and just play e6 and not develop
this Bishop and you're gonna end up in
an IQ P type of position if you like iqp
positions this one is perfectly fine for
black but I really do prefer bringing
this Bishop out to to g4 so those are
kind of your two options if you
absolutely hate the endgame line and I'm
going to avoid it although I do think
that black is perfectly fine in the
endgame line and then lastly we took a
look at this scary scary pan of attack
where this Bishop comes out to g5 and
starts putting some pressure on your
pieces alright I am going to open it up
to any questions on in this variation
the exchange variation I see one from
Brian Clark and say well just do some
questions for a couple minutes and then
call it here by the way if you guys are
interested I will be doing a twitch
class after this called tactics time
where I go over some tactics for you so
the end game variation was what I was
just asked about is the Queen trade the
only way to go for white the answer is
is honestly yes if you play Queen b3
you're going for this Queen trade almost
always I think there are one or two
games in lines where black or white
shows not to trade for example after
Queen d7 you could play move like Queen
c5 check although actually no you can't
that's a different line I'm thinking
takes takes now here you could play move
like Queen b3 or a move like we need to
check but
the fact is blacks queen is is just
gonna be better than yours we're gonna
play f6 and king f7 and this queen is
doing an excellent defensive job here
for black and the white queen is going
to get kicked around just a little bit
this is not a bad way of playing but I
do think that it's more beneficial to
black to have these Queens on the board
other than that if you don't want to go
for this line at all with white you can
play Bishop e2 here but now black really
just has a good version of the iqp where
blacks Bishop ended up getting developed
okay it's okay for you to put these
lines into chest bowls for your own
practice yes please do please do and on
that note a lot of these lines are the
same lines that L'Arche and orphe
actually recommends in his book the
grandmaster repertoire for the caro-kann
if you guys want a kind of complete book
on learning the cairo i would definitely
recommend that one it's definitely a
long one and it can be a bit dry at
times but as chest on chest content goes
it's one of the best to be sure and
that's actually where I learned most of
my lines for the Carroll although I did
change around quite a few that I wasn't
quite happy with but yeah I mean feel
free that the point of this lecture is
for you to learn the Cairo so do what
you need to do to learn it okay other
than that I think I'm going to call it
here thank you very much for joining me
this week on chess openings explained if
you're watching live feel free to stick
around to head over to a twitch channel
for tactics time if you're watching the
video this is where it ends thank you so
much for watching my name is caleb dummy
and I will see you next week
you
[Music]